cold distant and mysterious for decades
after its discovery in 1930 little was
known about the geology of pluto the
first scene from the earth pluto is just
a very tiny dot but it was approached by
a mission in 2015
called new horizon nasa's new horizons
probe was the first spacecraft to
explore pluto up close and it sent back
some fascinating images one of the
things that the mission could see was
some very intriguing polygonal patterns
and i was like wow that's very neat
what could explain these patterns the
patterns can be seen across the smooth
surface of a basin filled with nitrogen
ice
now a team of researchers has a new
explanation for pluto's mysterious
polygons
[Music]
looking at new horizons high-resolution
images of pluto several researchers were
intrigued by markings in the region
known as sputnik planitia where dark
lines formed geometric shapes several
tens of kilometers wide when it was
first observed uh the people that worked
on the mission they
very
rapidly thought about convection because
uh
thermal convection
in particular in
convection in solids
is known to make these type of patterns
even though sputnik clinicia is made of
solid ice slow-moving currents are still
the most likely explanation solids if
you look at them on long time scales
behave like liquids
we can see that with glaciers in
mountains we know that glaciers flow
down the mountain so they are like
rivers but very viscous rivers
the ice of sputnik planetsia is also
solid but it convex on time scales of
hundreds of thousand years the
convection currents that make these
kinds of patterns are usually driven by
heating from below that's what happens
when you
eat a
pan you can see patterns you can see you
know motion in the pan and that's caused
by convection
because the fluid that is below gets
less dense because it's
it gets warmer and so because it's below
and less dense it wants to move up
on the other side the fluid that is on
top it's cooler so it's more dense and
wants to go down but there was something
about the patterns on pluto's surface
that didn't quite fit with the idea of
convection currents being driven by
pluto's internal heat
eating from below would lead to actually
reversed patterns compared to what we
observe that is
flow going up on the polygons sides
instead of going down as we observe
the visible lines delineating the
polygons are troughs showing that the
convection currents must be rising up in
the center of each shape and sinking at
the edges the opposite to what you'd get
if you were heating from underneath so
we still think that convection is at the
origin of these polygons
but instead of eating from below
we think that it is better explained by
cooling the top to explain this cooling
stefan and his team turned to
sublimation
this is the process similar to
evaporation by which the nitrogen ice of
sputnik planitia turns from a solid
straight into a gas this cools down the
surface in a very similar way to the
situation we encounter in everyday life
when we get out of water and we feel
cold because water is evaporating which
requires latent heat to to do so and it
cools down the skin
and so we think that's exactly what's
happening to test this theory the team
developed a computer simulation of the
surface
and we found that with reasonable
parameters for sputnik planisia we
obtained the same type of patterns as
what we observe
their model shows for the first time
that sublimation can drive planetary
scale patterns
the team are confident in their findings
but it might be a while before all their
hypotheses can be fully tested it would
be good to go back there and test some
of the ideas that we propose but of
course this is very far away and it's
very difficult to send missions there
but i'm confident yes
you